it's a big experiment school's out
thanks to the coronavirus but millions
of children are learning online from
home an exciting challenge for some even
if it's just yoga for kids but the
digital playing field is anything but
level what if you don't have access to
the latest tech or your teacher can't
call you every day
access to education could leave a whole
lot of people behind hi i'm ben for
zulan the teachers i've spoken to you
think it's great the virtual classroom
puts the onus on children to discipline
themselves one and a half billion
students are off school around the world
but class has gone online for many in
nations with poor internet coverage kids
are turning to radio and TV but does
that put them at a disadvantage sixteen
year old Emily leah has been out of
school since March 18 schools were
closed in Cameroon in an effort to curb
the spread of the coronavirus a manner
not takes classes daily through
television lectures are given in English
and French the idea is to help students
like a manner who be taking his junior
high school exams in Jude I can see
that's really helping me
I know these are ideal for at least
three local TV stations are producing
similar programs teachers are paid by a
country's Education Ministry on this
station every teacher gets 20 minutes of
lecture time this Ambu has been an
English instructor for six years
teaching on camera is new for him all
children have right to education and if
this method can have them acquiring
knowledge or have that right enjoying
that right
I fully support it and also for the
reason that even adults can learn
through this method so I am on the
person for it due to frequent power
blackouts and monnel is forced to miss
some classes other students in Cameroon
have no access to TV sets at all and
mana wants to study medicine but his
concern his dreams will be delayed if
schools remain closed due to the
pandemic and the red slicer is a special
advisor on education policy at the
Organisation for Economic Cooperation
and Development how a kids dealing with
this leap in technology we I mean we are
talking about digital natives here but
at the end of the day it's their
education at stake yeah you have plenty
of children who are you know access to
the technology access to high quality
learning resources but it's not just a
matter of the digital resources learning
is always a relational process we learn
raised and from people so to study on
your own you need to have the motivation
to see the value of education you to
have the effective learning strategies
the resilience to struggle to you know
learn from failure with failure and it's
often those qualities that we are just
in developing in a way in the past be
spoon-fed
you know young people in school then we
gave them little chunks to learn and to
repeat now suddenly they have to study
on their own and that's a very very
different experience so apart from the
technology it's a novel experience there
are some students succeed very well you
know they have great support from the
parents they have you know great
motivation but many many young children
are left behind so with or without the
technology then what about children from
disadvantaged backgrounds or developing
countries well you know this crisis is
amplifying the inequalities that are
already inherent in our education
systems before we always travel to
attract
most talented teachers to the most
challenging classrooms to make sure that
every student has access to to excellent
teaching so I think in this moment is
very very important that education
systems redouble their efforts to reach
out to the families and the students who
struggle most and that means freeing up
some time from teachers to actually
dedicate to those those kids they will
not succeed just left on their own
devices you mentioned families there
what about parents yeah absolutely you
know I think it's a matter of connecting
this parents it's being you know parents
to this mission education is becoming a
whole of society project not just you
know it schooling priority you need to
support from parents you need to the
understanding for parents apparently to
give their children you know access to a
quiet place to study and that's not the
case for for our children they need to
give them access to the computer maybe
that they may also need for their work
so I think it's a sacrifice on
everybody's part do you feel this could
end up being a lost year for students
around the world well I hope not I don't
think we can afford it I think there
would be a terrible price for humanity
to pay and I also think we should be
cognizant of the many many good examples
I mean this crisis is liberated a lot of
energy education systems there's a lot
of front frontline capacity whereas
course you know operate with this
certificate you know follow me each
others are designers of innovative
learning environments those are actually
thriving at this moment and I think what
we should do is not into astonishing
ideas into classrooms spend more time on
you know finding those good ideas
sharing them scaling them spreading them
I think that's exactly what this needed
at this moment of time they are enormous
that there's there are teachers who
invest you know their lives to make this
work and I know we need to give them the
space in this to do Network let's have a
quick listen to what some students and
teachers think about online schooling to
me is funny it is easier to work at
school because the teacher explains
everything
and so Tom Gates then teaching the
actual school
I often feel totally overwhelmed we are
not trained to teach these things isn't
mr. su pedagogy shadows could build it's
fun
I find learning much easy at school
because I take an active role in class
when I sit in class I take a lot in and
therefore I have to do less at host of
MIT named Khan and Hauser and venial
tumors so Andres how can government's
make this work well I think examples you
know yeah there are many teachers who
are struggling but there were lots of
teachers full of motivation and energy
to make this work you know teachers who
are becoming good coaches good mentors
good facilitators I think what
governments need to do at this moment is
to direct resources where they can make
most of a difference typically we do the
opposite you know if you come from the
wealthy background we gives you the
better teacher the better school I think
in this moment Carolyn's need to look
harder where are the resources really
needed and how to direct them
governments also should you know think
heart of what students should learn at
this moment clearly you know learning
time will be reduced will shred we
cannot put that on the shoulders of
schools governments need to define what
is the essential part that really
students need to learn and prioritizing
you know learning is a very important
task for governments and then you know
providing teachers with good online
support yes it's a big challenge for
teachers teachers are not way back for
there if I think again you know teachers
can learn and if we give them the right
you know access to professional
development I think we will see the
quantum change right so I hear thank you
very much for joining us thank you 12
your questions now on the coronavirus
his Derek Williams could the virus
mutates if that happens how dangerous
would it be to answer this question we
have to first look at what mutation
means exactly now in biology
mutation describes alterations to the
genetic code in an organism or a virus
in a virus like SARS Cove to these
changes happen during replicas
Haitian when an invaded cell is churning
out new copies of the virus now all
viruses mutate it's it's how the
coronavirus jumped to humans in the
first place it mutated to do so moving
forward though what will be key is
exactly how the virus mutates can it
change in ways that make it more
infectious or that make it more deadly
that's what matters to us those kinds of
mutations are generally ones that have
an effect on the virus's physical
structures for example the spikes that
dot the outer surface of Sarrus cove two
that that allow it to latch on to human
cells so far although we know the new
corona virus will mutate and and we can
even track those mutations as the virus
spreads there's no evidence that it's
mutating into even more dangerous
strains but there's no way to rule out
that it might happen in the future
HIV still causes AIDS today with no real
vaccine or cure what are the odds Koba
19 could be the same the big reason why
we've struggled to come up with a
vaccine for HIV is that the process it
uses to produce copies of itself is very
prone to making mistakes so the virus
mutates rapidly most of those mistakes
won't work out but a few will prove
beneficial to the virus in the sense
that the changes will allow it to
continue to evade a patient's immune
system HIV is really a moving target so
it's hard to come up with an effective
vaccine but SARS Cove 2 is very
different from HIV in a very key way it
proofreads
its genetic code during replication and
proofreading slows the mutation rate
that means the SARS Cove 2 genomes so
far appears to remain stable or more
stable than HIV over time that's giving
researchers hope that they'll be able to
develop effective long lasting vaccines
again
the coronavirus but because we're still
at such an early stage of observing its
evolution it's still just a hope we
don't have hand sanitizer here someone
suggested using the cheapest gin makes
with aloe vera without work along with
toilet paper
hand sanitizer has become a hard-to-find
product in most parts of the world and
manufacturers have really struggled to
keep up with demand
so can you protect yourself by making
your own from distilled spirits alcohol
is the disinfecting component in most
hand sanitizers it works by unfolding
and and deactivating proteins that are
found in the outer envelope that codes
viruses like SARS co2
the problem with trying to make your own
hand sanitizer is that most spirits like
gin are only around 40 percent alcohol
which isn't enough to kill the virus
effectively
commercial hand sanitizers are around
60% alcohol by volume experts also warn
that homemade sanitizer can be bad for
your skin so in general it's probably a
good idea to stay away from them don't
forget there's a more straightforward
way to disinfect your hands just wash
them regularly for at least 20 seconds
with soap and warm water